عقدت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كما لاهرس
اجتماعا طارئا مع اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
وكندا واستراليا ونيوزيلندا على همشي قمه
افيك لبحث اطلاق كوري الشماليه صاروخا
بعيدا المدى و خلال الاجتماع دعت هارس
كوريا الشماليه الى وقف استفزازاتها وقال
البيت الابيض انه يدين بقوه اطلاق كوريا
الشماليه صاروخا بعيد المدى واضاف ان
واشنطن ستتخذ كافه الاجراءات لضمان امن
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
هذا وقال الجيش الكوريه الجنوبي كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت صاروخا يشتبه بانه بالستي
عابر للقارات وقال وزير الدفاع الياباني
انما ده الصاروخ كان كافيا لبلوغ اراضي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه جانبي قال
رئيس الوزراء الياباني
الصاروخ الكوريه الشمالي يعتقد انه سقط في
المياه الاقتصاديه
زمنت هذه تطورات مع انطلاق هي اعمال قمه
منتدى التعاون الاقتصادي لاسيا والمحيط
الهادئ ابك في العاصمه التايلانديه بانكوك
لبحث التنميه الاقتصاديه المستدامه
والمتوازنه الاقتصادات الدول المطله على
المحيط الهداف يشاركه في القمه الرئيس
الصيني سجن بينج ولعيبه الرئيس الامريكي
كمالهارس رئيس الوزراء الياباني
التجمع الاقليميه الوحيد الذي يضم في
عضويته
القمه على وقع التوتر في بحر جنوب الصين
وتوفري اقتصاديه الدول بالحرب في اوكرانيا
معنى من قمه منتدى التعاون الاقتصاديه
لاسيا والمحيط الهادي ابيكال منعقده في
العاصمه تايلانديه بانكوك مراسل الجزيره
صهيب الجاسم صهيب جاسم اذن هذا الصاروخ
البالستيه الكوري الشماليه هو ما عقد هذه
القمه الطارعه لهامش قمه افيك كيف بالفعل
القي او القت بغلالها على هذا الاجتماع
قبل ايام او قبل ثلاث ايام عندما في خلال
القمه مجموعه العشرين في صبيحه اليوم
الثاني عندما عقد الرئيس الامريكي مؤتمر
او عقد قمه عاجله لدول السبع الكبار
واضافه الى اليابان عندما وقع الانفجار في
بولندا يؤثر هذه الاحداث السياسيه غير
الاقتصاديه على قيمه اقتصاديه اليوم هنا
نحن في قمه اسيا والمحيط قمه التعاون
الاقتصادي رئاسي والمحيط الهادي وهي قمه
اقتصادات ولذلك فيها عضويه
تايوان على انهم اقتصادات في هذه المنطقه
ولهم التقدير اقتصاديا يحدث هذه القمه مره
اخرى وتواجه ازمه سياسيه اخرى
تازهم اخر في منطقه همم شمال شرق اسيا نحن
ان الرئيس الصيني والرئيس الوزراء
الياباني اجتمع يوم امس في قمه ثنائيه
وبحث هذا الامر وبحث في منطقه التوتر في
المنطقه الاقتصاديه اليابانيه التي حدث
فيها حادثه اليوم حيث عبر رئيس الوزراء
الياباني عن طريقه لما يحصل فيه مضيقي
تايوان وقال بانه لابد ان يحافظ على الامن
والاستقرار للمنطقه حفاظا على تطور
والتنميه الاقتصاديه اليوم يحدث ما حصل في
كوريا الشماليه ليؤثر مره اخرى على مؤتمر
اقتصادي هذا المؤتمر لا يمكن ان ينفك
كغيره من القمم التي حصلت في جنوب شرق
اسيا عن الاوضاع الاقليميه والتوتر الحاصل
التوتر الحاصل في بعض جنوب الصين وفي شرق
همم وفي شرق الصين وبالتالي هناك ربما
تساؤلات حول ما يمكن ان تخرج به هذه القمه
من اتفاق على بعض الامور وربما اختلاف على
امور اخرى هناك تساؤل ما اذا سيتفق على
بيان ختامي او ربما ستكون الامر مختصره
على ملاحظات وبيان من رئاسه القمه من قبل
همم من قبل ومن قبل الحكومه بتاع الانديه
المضيفه هذه الامور كلها طبعا تتدفع
بالحديث عن توجهات مختلفه في هذه القمه
رئيس الرئيس الصيني كان تحدث على انه يجب
ان تبقى هذه المنطقه منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادي خاليه وتناى بنفسها عن اي صراعات
وقال بانها ليست حديقه خلفيه لاي احد لكن
اليوم من خطاب سيكون الخطاب الغربيا لاحد
خلفاء واحد المقربه من الصين كوريا
الشماليه وربما سنتوقع تنديدا هناك اكثر
مؤتمر صحفي متوقع هذا اليوم ويتوقع بشكل
واضح انه ستكون هناك التمديدات ومواقف
معينه سياسيه في هذه المنطقه الحضور
الحضور الامريكي في هذه المنطقه بحضور
الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدن في قمه اسيا قبل
ايام ثم في قمه مجموعه العشرين ثم حضور
نائبه الرئيس
كمالها هاريس في هذه القمه ثم توجهها الى
الفلبين بعد يومين او ثلاثه ايام كل هذه
مؤشرات ايضا امريكيه واضحه بانها تعود
تهتم بهذه المنطقه ولا تريد الحلفائها
سواء كوريا الشمائل كوريا الجنوبيه او
اليابان او الفلبين او دول اخرى مثل ثاني
دول اندونيسيا لا تريد من هذه الدول ان
تبقى بشعور انها تركت من قبل المتحده
تواجهها التمدد الصيني العسكري وايضا
الخطر الكوري الشمالي
من بانكوك حيث قمه منتدى التعاون
الاقتصادي لاسيا والمحيط الهادي ابيك
مراسل الجزيره صهيب جاسم شكرا جزيلا لك